انسحبت وتوتر اذا من الميثاق ليزيد القلق
خاصه وان عددا من الدول ستشهد انتخابات
الفتره المقبله لكن هذا القلق موجود اصلا
من وقت تولي ماسك اطلق ماسك الاشتراك
الشهري للمستخدمين ليحصلوا على علامه
التحقق امر استغله البعض اشتروا العلامات
ونشروا المعلومات المضلله وفقا لمنظمه
نيوزجارد للمراقبه قام ماسك باعاده تفعيل
6700 حساب كانت قد علقت بسبب الانتهاكات
لكن هذا العدد الفعلي ربما يكون اكثر
بكثير المبرمج المقيم في المانيات رابس
براون جمع قائمه تضم اكثر من 67 الف حساب
على تويتر اعيد تفعيلها منذ استحواذ ماسك
على المنصه وبالتالي زادت المعلومات
المضلله لكن ما هو رد ماسك
حسنا هل تعرف من يقول ان شيئا ما هو
معلومات مضلله من هو الحكم على ذلك حسنا
اذا يجب ان تكون قد رايت في بعض النقاط
معتقدت انه محتوى كراهيه
انا اسال عن مثال واحد لا يمكن اعطائي
مثالا واحدا
امثله
المنشورات المناهضه للقاحات والمنشورات
الداعمه لما يسمى بالنازيين الجدد
والمؤمنين بتفوق العرق الابيض رابطه
مكافحه التشهير ايدي ال نشرت تحقيقا هي
الاخرى ردت قرار ماسك خلق مساحاتنا لنشر
نظريات المؤامره وانواع اخرى من الكراهيه
المنشورات الخاصه بنظريه المؤامره التي
اختلقها اليمين الامريكي زادت بنسبه واحد
وتسعين في المئه بين مايو 2022 ومايو من
هذا العام الحالي نشرت ثلاثه ارباع هذه
الرساله بعد استحواذ ماسك
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات